Michael, where do you live?
I live in Florida.
Where's Florida?
Florida is in the southeast part of America.
Our house is in a small city called Jensen Beach.
Wow, that's amazing!
Do you want to take a tour of the house?
Yeah!
Let's go!
This is the bathroom.
I wash my hands in the bathroom.
This is the kitchen.
I cook in the kitchen.
This is the dining room.
I eat food in the dining room.
Michael drinks coffee in the dining room.
This is the living room.
Michael's mom watches TV in the living room.
Let's go outside.
This is the patio.
I relax and read books on the patio.
Michael takes naps on the patio.
This is the garden.
I plant seeds in the garden.
This is the backyard.
I love to climb trees.
Hey, Katya!
Catch!
This is the swimming pool.
I swim in the swimming pool.